cette vidéo est sponsorisé par petits
bonds vous vous en parle plus longuement
à la fin de la vidéo
elle est folle cette question non je
trouve me retourne le cerveau quoi parce
qu'a priori on mesure pas maintenant on
ressent dans une vidéo d'il ya quatre
ans vous faisait cette citation
qu'est-ce donc que le temps si personne
ne me demande je le sais mais si on me
le demande et que je veuille l'expliquer
je ne sais plus saint-augustin
d'ailleurs je trouve ça intéressant de
creuser le sujet des sens on nous parle
beaucoup de l'ouïe l'odorat la vue le
goût le toucher et on a d'autres aussi
l'écholocalisation qui nous permet
d'appréhender notre environnement en
fonction des ondes sonores qui se
répercute sur les murs et les objets la
proprioception c'est à dire la
perception de son propre corps donc
c'est ce qui va nous permettre par
exemple de manger certaines mettre
quelque chose dans notre bouche sans
pouvoir voir notre bouche les kilos brio
ception c'est à dire le sens de l'
équilibre tout simplement ou encore la
thermo exception c'est à dire la
perception de la chaleur ou de l'absence
de la chaleur mais le temps ressentir le
temps la perception du temps on en parle
non non justement on n'en parle pas on
n'en parle pas tellement c'est évident
et quand je parle d' évidence je parle
d'évidence métaphysique c'est quelque
chose d'immédiat n'y a pas d' analyse il
n'y a pas de réflexion
ça nous est donné entièrement
immédiatement si vous ça que cette
question elle est forte parce qu'on se
la posent jamais passe comme s'il n'y
avait pas de réponse et pourtant il y en
a plein et pour vous en parler
correctement j'ai envie de vous parler
de marque whitman
il est chercheur à l'institute for
frontiers of psychology mtf à fribourg
en allemagne et il a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle fait le times the psychology
of a wimpy steve times mark whitman nous
parle de trois différents moments
fonctionnment experiment et mentaux
présence
je vais les traduire par moments
fonctionnel moment ressenti et présence
notable le moment fonctionnel c'est la
première granularité c'est le plus petit
élément de notre conscience temporel
c'est grâce à ça si on réalise si deux
événements arrivent simultanément ou non
donc c'est très précis ça va de 0 à 300
millisecondes
ça va très vite et parfois ça va pas
assez vite
il peut y avoir un très court laps de
temps entre le moment où un événement a
lieu et le moment où
perçoit cet événement est d'ailleurs nos
sens ne sont pas égaux par rapport à ça
par exemple auditivement on est assez
chaud parce qu'il suffit d'un écart de 2
à 3 millisecondes entre deux stimuli
pour qu'on les considère comme non
simultanées alors qu'au niveau de la
vision on est plus autour des 10
millisecondes et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que c'est pas parce
que ces noms simultanée que notre
cerveau est capable de savoir lequel est
arrivé en premier je trouve ça fou alors
tout ce que je vous dis là est tiré
d'une seule et même étude je vous mets
quand même comme ça vous savez que je
vous dis pas n'importe quoi
vous êtes en train de regarder un
contenu de qualité vous pouvez vous
applaudir ça c'est est ce qu'on va
appeler le moment fonctionnel il va donc
de 3 millisecondes à 300 millisecondes
ok maintenant on va parler du experiment
le moment ressenti le moment ressenti il
va de 300 millisecondes à 3000
millisecondes soit trois secondes c'est
dans ces trois secondes que notre
impression de maintenant arrive
d'où cette phrase de paul inquiets qui a
fait l'étude dont j'ai parlé juste avant
qui dit la chose suivante
we take life freescale atteint qu'on
pourrait traduire par on prend l'avis
par tranche de 3 secondes
ces trois secondes c'est la durée la
plus longue de maintenant et popol il
prend un exemple fort celui du métronome
prenons un métronome 220 battements par
minute
c'est constant et c'est le même son et
pourtant je peux faire des groupements
différent je peux faire 1 2 1 2 1 2 ou
bien je peux faire 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 ces
différences principales entre le moment
fonctionnel et le moment ressenti je
peux recevoir les stimuli passivement
ou bien je peux influé sur ma manière de
recevoir les stimuli et vous remarquerez
que ça marche tant que l'intervalle
entre les sons ne dépasse pas une
seconde plus ça devient compliqué par
exemple sur du 60 des pme
ça devient difficile on peut
difficilement les regrouper par trois
pôles est d'ailleurs allé plus loin
parce qu'il a remarqué que dans le
phrasé dans de nombreuses langues
étudiées quand c'est naturel et donc pas
quand on lit un texte par exemple eh ben
on va parler par groupe de trois
secondes
je crois que c'est exactement ce que je
veux faire
[Musique]
alors évidemment quand on dit que ces
trois secondes ces deux lors de
l'estimation
l'idée c'est de dire que c'est pas des
millisecondes et que c'est pas des
dizaines de secondes on a donc vu le
moment fonctionnel et le moment ressenti
mais si on s'attache à ces concepts là
on aurait l'impression juste de vivre
une succession d'instants présent or
c'est pas ça on a une impression globale
on ne ressent qu'un seul présent sur ça
qu'il faut qu'on parle des menthol
présence la présence mentale qui va de
quelques secondes à quelques minutes la
présence mentale est fait appel à notre
mémoire de travail
c'est un modèle fonctionnel de la
mémoire à court terme qui est proposée
par alan brown c'est une digression mais
en gros la différence entre les deux
c'est que la mémoire à court terme elle
est généralement exposés comme une
mémoire pouvant nous permettre de
maintenir temporairement une information
alors que la mémoire de travail
ces exposés comme une mémoire qui va
nous permettre non seulement de
maintenir temporairement une information
mais aussi de la manipuler donc la
présence mentale est fait appel à cette
notion de mémoire du travail qui va nous
permettre de traiter des informations et
des stimuli pour une période de temps
qui excède quelques secondes et donc ça
va nous donner cette sensation
uniformiser de présent et donc ses
limites sont beaucoup plus flou que le
moment fonctionnelle ou le moment
ressenti puisque en fait ça va dépendre
de ce qu'on a gardé dans cette mémoire
de travail et ça s'effrite en fait
graduellement les expériences de
perception de niveau inférieur
s'imbriquent donc dans le niveau
supérieur
la présence mentale les moments ressenti
que je vis sont imbriqués dans la
présence mentale quand part d'un instant
présent qu'on a vécu on fait écho à ces
moments ressenti de quelques secondes
mais c'est la présence mentale dans
laquelle tout s'imbrique qui fait qu'on
a la conscience de son soit présent avec
sa narration et ses commentaires whitman
dit c'est la conscience de moi même en
tant que conscience qui perçoit
maintenant et il a une image très belle
je trouve pour parler du moment présent
puisqu'il parle de la vague de l'ice bar
une rivière artificielle à munich elle
suit constamment le flot de l'eau et en
même temps elle varie extrêmement peu
comme cette sensation très stable du
moment présent
qu'est ce que c'est beau nan mais sans
déconner je trouve ça magnifique quan on
est dans de la poésie aujourd'hui joue
jeu
voilà on est là mais je sens l'eau de
rose ou quoi j'en ai pas fini avec vous
il y a une autre manière d'aborder la
question et lé cosmique cette fois du
point de vue d'un photon se maintenant
le maintenant du big bang tous les
maintenant entre les deux et les
maintenant à venir arrivent tous
simultanément donc d'un point de vue
cosmique maintenant n'a pas de sens ou
est-ce que ça s'arrête quand est-ce que
ça s'arrête ça va trop loin ça va trop
loin
j'adore moi j'aime les trucs mind boeing
comme ça et tout et j'adore j'ai besoin
de prendre claque sur claques j'ai pris
un plaisir à écrire cette vidéo vous
n'imaginez pas alors maintenant qu'on
peut estimer combien de temps dure
maintenant et surtout qu'est ce que
c'est que maintenant on peut se poser
une autre question essentielle comment
vivre dans maintenant dans l'instant
présent et surtout à quoi ça sert
stoïcisme bouddhisme il ya beaucoup de
philosophie de bonheur qui le prônent
j'en ai déjà parlé sur cette chaîne et
je pense que je vais en reparler mais je
voulais vous parler d'un outil clé pour
ça c'est la méditation c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que j'ai fait des lives
méditation guidée pendant tout le
premier confinement et aujourd'hui je
suis très content et très fier d'avoir
comme sponsor de cette vidéo petit bon
instant promo petit bambou c'est
vraiment une nappe que je recommande à
chaque fois parce que j'ai vraiment vu
des gens l'utilisent et autour de moi et
voir à quel point ça les a aidés dans
leur vie de tous les jours moi je vais
être honnête avec vous je fais très peu
de méditation guidée parce que j'en ai
fait beaucoup à un moment et genre
manière intensive donc maintenant je
mets juste un timer mais à chaque fois
que vous m'écrivez pour me demander
conseil sur une nappe de méditation
guidée
je vous conseille toujours au minimum
petits bonbons très franchement c'est
pour ça que je suis très content de
faire ce partenariat avec aujourd'hui je
me dis tous les jours la méditation fait
partie de ma vie et je vous encourage à
faire de même
on demande souvent quoi ça sert ça sert
à s'écouter davantage - jugé être
présent à soi-même et appréhender les
événements extérieurs avec plus de
sérénité ars par miracle c'est une
activité qu'on fait qu'on pratique nous
comme toutes les activités parfois c'est
très cool parfois c'est chiant voilà et
la méditation d'ailleurs nous aide à
accepter ça donc vous allez pas oublier
tous vos problèmes en méditant ça c'est
faux mais ça va vous aider à être plus à
l'aise avec et un programme de
découverte avec huit séances disponible
pour toutes et tous ils ont aussi une
fonctionnalité qui s'appelle la
méditation du jour avec une méditation
qui
ange par jour avec des voies différentes
etc vous pouvez mettre la durée que vous
voulez entre huit minutes 12 minutes 16
minutes suivant le temps que vous avez
vous mets le lien description checker au
moins le programme de découverte je suis
sûr que ça vous parlera et que est
vraiment ça peut vous apporter quelque
chose j'espère que ça vous plaira
j'attends vos retours en tout cas
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu ça
fait très longtemps que j'avais envie de
faire cette vidéo a été dans mes sujets
de trucs que je jouais dont je voulais
parler quoi parce que cette question m'a
vraiment retourné la tête j'espère que
vous avez quand j'ai eu et j'ai trouvé
folle du coup je me suis dit il fallait
une réponse et nous les bat tous les
mardis 22 heures sur tout i love peace
ciao